How did a real-life cowboy go from rodeo
shows to appearing in "Midnight, Texas?"
How did that same actor land on just about every
Western and quasi-Western movie and television
show of the last 20 years? Let's dive into
the long and varied career of Forrie J. Smith.
There's a reason why the wise, rugged Lloyd Pierce
on "Yellowstone" imbues his scenes with such an
air of realism. As it turns out, the actor behind
the long-time Dutton employee, Forrie J. Smith,
is a real-life cowboy with decades of experience
under his large-buckled belt. That experience
served him well as both a stunt man and an actor,
and throughout his decades-long career in show
business, Smith has been back in the saddle more
times than one could count. This, perhaps, is why
the charismatic and occasionally mysterious Lloyd
Pierce looks so familiar to viewers. Beginning
in the late 1980s, the actor found himself
starring in several television movies, TV series,
and films, and in each one managed to prove
that, as a performer, he was no one-trick pony.
"No room for outcasts like us in the bunkhouse."
By 1993, Forrie J. Smith had several off-screen
and minor roles under his belt. He was
mostly known for his work as a stuntman
in "Rambo III" when he took on the role of
Pony Deal in writer Kevin Jarre's "Tombstone."
The film told the story of gunslingers
and occasional lawmen Wyatt Earp and Doc
Holliday's involvement in the infamous 1881
shoot-out at the O.K. Corral in Tombstone,
Arizona. The movie's cast was stacked with
A-listers, but even among the superstars
Smith managed to make an impression—with
future casting directors, at least.
Though Smith's role in the film was as a
non-speaking ensemble member of the criminal
Clanton Gang, the film's success helped the
experienced stunt man showcase his stage skills.
Four years after his role as a rambunctious
cowboy in "Tombstone," Forrie J. Smith starred
alongside Javier Bardem, Rosie Perez, and James
Gandolfini in director Álex de la Iglesia's
critically acclaimed dark comedy, "Perdita
Durango." Strutting onto the scene, Smith's
Armendariz attempts to negotiate with a fellow
criminal before being killed in a shoot-out.
Although the scene is relatively short, it allowed
Smith to fully embrace and embody a character with
some semblance of a backstory. The film's cult
status helped the already prolific and in-demand
"additional crew" cowboy flex his acting chops.
The year prior, Smith had starred in a short
scene in the made-for-TV movie, "Ruby Jean
and Joe," wherein he delivered a few drunken
lines at a birthday party before getting
punched in the face by Tom Selleck. Still,
it was hardly as big an on-screen moment for
the actor as his shoot-out in Perdita Durango.
Though Forrie J. Smith's screen time in Duncan
Tucker's Oscar-nominated "Transamerica" was short,
his dialogue in the scene acts as a catalyst for a
critical moment for the film's
protagonists. In the movie,
a religious, conservative woman named Bree, who
is saving up for sex reassignment surgery, is
compelled by her therapist to track down the son
she unknowingly fathered while still in college.
Bree heads to New York to track
down her son, but since she is
unable to explain the true nature of her
relationship to the street-hustler teen,
she pretends to be a Christian case-worker.
The two embark on a cross-country journey
back to L.A. and, along the way, stop at a
roadside market in Arizona called Sammy's Wigwam.
Smith plays Sammy, who assumes the
angsty teen is the woman's child,
and when Toby swears at Bree,
Smith's character chastises him.
"You watch your mouth around your mother."
"She is not my mother. she's not anyone's
mother, she's not even a real woman."
It's an important moment in developing the
characters' relationship and vindicates
Bree's fears, and her motivations for lying to
Toby, while illustrating that the two very much
already come off as a parent and child. Smith's
success following his role in "Transamerica"
is proof that sometimes it's more about quality
than quantity when it comes to screen-time.
By 2017, Forrie J. Smith had established
himself as the man to call when casting
directors were looking for a real-life wrangler
and horseman who also knew how to deliver a line.
In 2013, he provided his animal wrangler
skills to the crew of "2 Guns." In 2016,
he worked with future "Yellowstone" creator
Taylor Sheridan as an animal wrangler on the
Oscar-nominated "Hell or High Water." While
one would be hard-pressed to recognize Smith
in either film, he had a more visible role in
the "Breaking Bad" spin-off, "Better Call Saul."
In the Season 3 episode "Mabel," Smith stars
as the junkyard owner of Five J's Auto Salvage,
who loans Mike some tools and space to work.
In 2018, Forrie J. Smith lent his characteristic
Western aesthetic to NBC's "Midnight, Texas."
The town of Midnight is a safe place for
outsiders, who fit the category mainly
based on their supernatural characteristics. Among
that cast of outsiders is former "weretiger," the
now-cured Reverend Emilio Sheehan. In the
episode "To Witch Hell and Back," viewers
learn the origin of Sheehan's identity and watch
as he struggles to come to terms with his past.
Smith appears in the flashback as the real
Reverend Emilio Sheehan, a priest and cowboy
who was killed by the transformed weretiger years
ago. When the weretiger transformed into his human
self again, he took on the priest's identity,
wracked with guilt and determined to atone.
Smith's real-life experience clearly helps
him get across the rugged realism of the
characters he plays. That seems to be true
whether he's being attacked by a weretiger
or doing the Dutton's dirty work on "Yellowstone."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.